death is the solution to all problems
no man no problem
the death of one man is a tragedy the
death of millions as a statistic
remember how the first world war broke
out it broke out as a result of the
desire to redivide the world
[Music]
i know that after my death a pile of
rubbish will be heaped on my grave but
the wind of history will sooner or later
sweep it away without mercy
[Music]
in war i would deal with the devil and
his grandmother
artillery is the god of war
in the soviet army it takes more courage
to retreat than advance
it takes a brave man to be a coward in
the red army
[Music]
if the opposition disarms well and good
if it refuses to disarm we shall disarm
it ourselves
gaiety is the most outstanding feature
of the soviet union
we can exist peacefully together if we
don't indulge in too much mutual fault
finding in all kinds of trifles
it is enough that the people know there
was an election
the people who cast the votes decide
nothing
the people who count the votes decide
everything
a sincere diplomat is like dry water or
wooden iron
[Music]
if any foreign minister begins to defend
to the death of peace conference you can
be sure his government has already
placed its orders for new battleships
and airplanes
[Music]
the leaders come and go but the people
remain only the people are immortal
[Music]
ah these diplomats what chatter boxes
there's only one way to shut them up cut
them down with machine guns
bulgano go and get me one
[Music]
history shows that there are no
invincible armies
nobody respects a country with a poor
army but everybody respects a country
with a good army
i raise my toast to the finnish army
[Music]
everyone imposes his own system as far
as his army can reach
print as the sharpest and the strongest
weapon of our party
when we hang the capitalists they will
sell us the rope we use
take some exercise try to recover the
look of a human being
[Music]
education is a weapon whose effects
depend on who holds it in his hands and
at whom it is aimed
[Music]
it is not heroes that make history but
history that makes heroes
i believe in one thing only the power of
human will
the writer is the engineer of the human
soul
quantity has a quality all its own
[Music]
music's a good thing it calms the beast
in the man
we are 50 or 100 years behind the
advanced countries we must make good
this distance in 10 years either we do
it or they will crush us
[Music]
die but do not retreat
principles triumph they do not
compromise
the only way a kid is going to practice
is if it's total fun for him and it was
for me
[Music]
i trust no one not even myself
[Music]
gratitude is a sickness suffered by dogs
[Music]
you cannot make a revolution with silk
gloves
[Music]
women are attracted to the emotional
strength of men and turned off by any
emotional weaknesses a guy has
everybody has a right to be stupid but
some people abuse the privilege
[Music]
the pope how many divisions has he got
how do you expect the germans to revolt
when they don't even dare walk on the
grass
you do not lament the loss of hair of
one who has been beheaded
[Music]
a man's eyes should be torn out if he
can only see the past
[Music]
you